August 29 2021 you might remember Joe
Biden probably does not recall he does
not know
that today is Thursday
but however what happened on that day we
will never forget that is the day that
the remains of 13 U.S service members
that were killed in that suicide bombing
uh near the Kabul Airport arrived at
Dover Airfield for a dignified transfer
now President Joe Biden was standing on
the tarmac remember he's checking his
watch again again and again it was so
insulting embarrassing multiple times
pretty disgraceful but it was the
culmination of Joe Biden's disastrous
withdrawal from Afghanistan and frankly
one of the most shameful humiliating
moments in American history we have a
few new ones the Chinese spy balloon and
the Drone shot out of the sky we'll get
to that now despite the gravity of the
situation the Biden Administration they
only waited until today today for people
that may not be at the Christian faith
is Holy Thursday tomorrow is Good Friday
Sunday is Easter Sunday now just before
the Easter Sunday weekend they finally
released their assessment of what went
wrong and they're trying to bury the
story on and not let us figure out what
actually went wrong they're not telling
us the truth in fact the assessment from
Biden is so dishonest it's something
that we have come to expect from all the
administration because they pretty much
lie about everything if the dog bites
bee stings feeling sad who do you blame
Donald
there you go now when you raise your
kids think about this all kids do silly
things right they make mistakes do you
get more mad at the mistake or do you
get mad when they try to insult your
intelligence and lie to you well that
and blame others for their decision and
their behavior well that defines Joe
Biden and his entire Administration and
all the hacks that speak for him now
they blame Donald Trump for covid for
bank failures the Ohio train derailment
gas prices the border the Border really
okay the national debt inflation the war
in Ukraine spy balloons and so much more
nothing is ever Joe's fault just listen
to this uh explainer from John Kirby
take a look
nowhere in here does there appear to be
any uh expression of accountability or
mistake by either the president himself
or others is there any for what happened
I I would argue that the very fact that
we voluntarily
the agencies voluntarily decided to go
conduct after Action reviews nobody told
them to do that who's going to get fired
over this
Peter
the purpose of the document that we're
putting out today uh is to sort of
collate the chief reviews and findings
of the agencies that did after Action
reviews
um the it it's not the purpose of it is
not accountability
right according to Biden uh Biden did
nothing wrong he accepts no
responsibility frankly for anything now
he's learned nothing at all also and
it's really important you know not to
assign blame here well except for all
the times uh that the report blamed
Donald Trump they kept blaming Donald
Trump he wasn't president during the
chaotic withdrawal not a single American
was killed by the Taliban uh in
Afghanistan in combat in the last 18
months when Donald Trump was president
and meanwhile Joe Biden had been sworn
in for six months when he ordered this
withdrawal but according to the
administration's findings it's all
Donald Trump's fault and during the
transition from the Trump Administration
to the Biden Administration the outgoing
Administration provided they said no
plan for how to conduct the final
withdrawal in other words how could Joe
Biden ever possibly come up with his own
plan before ordering the withdrawal
maybe that's too much to ask from your
commander-in-chief now the report also
accuses Trump of emboldening the Taliban
and not leaving enough troops for Biden
to pull out well Joe you could have put
some back in and as for the billions in
military equipment that Joe left behind
billions and billions of it for the
Taliban well that's Biden's fault uh
apparently not take a look
and looking through this it doesn't seem
to address the seven billion dollars in
military hardware and technology that
was left in Afghanistan for the Taliban
you know the president took office in
January the withdrawal happened in
August does the president take
responsibility for for leaving all or
some of that you know who was
responsible for that equipment
the Afghans
the Afghans are responsible maybe if you
would have planned a properly you would
have pulled them out and maybe 13
Americans would be alive today if you
were a real commander-in-chief if you
knew what day of the week it was and
that you came up with your own plan
instead of blaming everybody else what
do you get mad at your kids you tell
your kids don't eat the cookie and then
all of a sudden they say okay I'm not
going to eat the cookie then you come
back five minutes later there's
chocolate all over their face you ask
them did they eat the cookie no I did
not Donald Trump ate the cookie
you know because that's what they they
take responsibility for nothing and by
the way
John Kirby just doesn't know what all
the fuss is about today he actually said
that he didn't see get this any chaos at
all during this withdrawal let me remind
him take a look
and so for all this talk of chaos I just
didn't see it not from my perch at one
point during the evacuation there was an
aircraft taking off full of people
Americans and Afghans alike every 48
minutes and not one single mission was
missed so I'm sorry I just won't buy the
whole argument of chaos it was tough in
the first few hours you would expect it
to be there was nobody at the airport
nobody at the airport oh
[Applause]
looks like people at the airport to me
are you serious the airport was
surrounded by Afghans and American
citizens dying to get out believing in
the promise of their president that no
American would be left behind and you
had Isis linked terrorists all while the
Taliban fighters were running security
at the checkpoints and it took days for
desperate Americans and foreign
Nationals to even get inside the airport
if they were lucky and they were then on
their own with many literally paying for
private security to keep them alive
during the entire ordeal babies were
being tossed remember this over airport
walls a moat of raw sewage formed around
the airport at one point dozens of
Afghans rushing the tarmac look at this
remember oh well John Kirby said this
didn't happen what you're seeing didn't
happen and then they attempted to cling
to the outside of a transport plane
because they were that desperate to get
the hell out of hell are you kidding me
and after days of all of this chaos Isis
carried out a suicide bombing killing
well over a hundred Afghans and that and
13 U.S service members now those that
did manage to escape they were packed
into cargo planes like this with
virtually no security vetting at all
whatsoever but John Kirby Joe Biden just
they're not able to see the kiosks from
that Vantage Point apparently they don't
pay attention if they'd only watched
this show their IQ would go up a hundred
percent immediately now of course many
American citizens
didn't make didn't get inside the
airport before Biden closed up chop left
them all behind and abandoned our
Americans Behind Enemy Lines only days
after vowing to stay until every single
American was safely uh let out of the
country you might remember Joe's promise
to this day Americans are still trapped
in Afghanistan with some according to
even last week wink and blinken your
secretary of state that he admitted over
175 Americans are there and some of them
are hostages take a look
Mr secretary how many American citizens
and licensed permanent residents are in
Afghanistan today and are any of them
currently being held hostage by the
Taliban uh Congressman there are several
Americans who are being detained by the
uh the Taliban uh we are working to
secure their freedom later he said
several he defines several as 175 and I
doubt that's a real number also these
Americans now have been trapped for
years Behind Enemy Lines some held
hostage while Biden does nothing to free
them now sadly this display of weakness
has very far-reaching consequences
Russia China Iran North Korea they are
all emboldened and Biden has now
abdicated America's leadership role on
the world stage that's why they're
taking full advantage that's why little
rocket man is back shooting off his new
missiles into the Sea of Japan that's
why Iran is now enriching uranium faster
than ever that is why China kind of flew
that spy balloon over the continental
U.S for days circling back to collect
data on our nuclear and Military sites
and successfully we now know they did it
successfully and we're transmitting that
data back to China in real time that's
why Russia well they invaded Ukraine you
think that they didn't think that Joe
Biden would do a thing taken out an
American drone over international waters
what were those consequences what were
the consequences for the Communist
Chinese nothing nothing and nothing and
now Russia has detained yet another
American a Wall Street Journal reporter
I hope we pray for him and all the
people stuck in Afghanistan and we're
praying for this safe return in the past
two years this world under Joe Biden has
become a far more dangerous place and I
fear it's only going to get worse and
it's no wonder that only a third of
Americans think that Joe Biden deserves
to be re-elected look at this fake new
CNN poll even they had to report at
least partial at least part of the story
a majority of Democrats they don't want
Joe they want another option Kamala
Harris go right ahead hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else